sehr geehrte zuseher mein name ist
obmann christoph hofmeister für mich da
kommen natürlich dass sie heute aus der
viele horror kaserne beim pioneer
parlaments zur feierlichen angelobung
der 200 rekruten vom einigungstermin
juni und juli begrüßen wir starten jetzt
in kürze die angelobung mit dem
angenehmen signal vielen dank fürs zu
sehen die wünschen gute unterhaltung
[Musik]
das ganze zur meldung das ganze
obwohl sich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hmm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und
der heutigen angelobung der kaserne
mein name ist europa ich werde sie durch
den ablauf der angliederung begleiten
und de.com mit deutschland erfolgen
unter ausschluss der staatsmittel moussa
bildungs und entwicklungsarbeit
das ist magento modul ermöglicht endlich
auch brustenge unter veranstaltungen
teilzunehmen
die angliederung wird in form ändern
direktübertragung leicht über youtube
übergang
wir begrüßen alle zuschauer die ihr
youtube live unter anderem teilnehmen
unsere steckt voller ruß
die täter feuerten die barrieren weiter
gut standen von der siegener begrüße ich
oberst klaus schmid maier als draußen
griechischen den kommandanten des kurier
billionen 1 wobei es folgen werden ist
es folgen der hitze des gefechts der
katholischen militärseelsorge zuge kämen
franzi und der evangelischen der sich
sogar millionärin tobacco bat johannes
kues die zugegeben das militär muss ich
kämpfen
[Musik]
herr musste die wie karate bedrohten es
war ein ungewöhnliches experiment das
den chancen nicht im zweiten end 1250
zugestehen wird bevor wirklichkeit des
deutschen reiches kröll war er könig von
sizilien an welche menschen dort entlang
aller sprachen alles kann ihnen zu hause
stellte sich die frage welche straße ist
endlich die nicht gestattet
welches ist eigentlich die wurde straff
welche sprache ein mensch und sicher
sprechen wenn keiner ihnen die strafen
bei gewinnen würde und um das
herauszufinden startete er als
experiment er schickte seine gene an ein
waisenhaus in dem kinder versorgt und
großgezogen wurden wie von ihrem opa mit
partner verlassen worden waren und die
die wir sollten 50 säuglinge bringen die
erst wenige tage oder wochen reitwagen
pressestelle für jedes kind eine
pflegerin den kind alles geben sollte
was es zum leben braucht essen trinken
kleidung aber eine stufe die kläger
wenden kind nicht geben
lieber herr jedes wort ein freundliches
an lassen
gesungen und welche sprache haben die
kinder dann und sich ausgesprochen
radrennen alle kinder wünscht und
lernten räder zu sprechen noch zu
spielen oder sich zu freuen
sie lernt nicht zu denken oder zu fragen
sie lernten nicht zu liegen und keines
von ihnen überlebte eine strafe nach
einer gewissen zeit ein unmenschliches
experiments das zu einem klaren resultat
geführt hat jeder mensch hat ein
urbedürfnis nach worten und taten der
liebe ohne die er nicht leben haben
riecht der mensch lebt nicht vom brot
allein sondern von einer jedem wort das
aus dem grund gottes lebt ohne gottes zu
rendern und ohne die zuwendung die wir
einander gehen sind wir tot geräte
menschliche zuwendung ist vor allem
heutzutage wichtig wo viele menschliche
auch durch die digitalisierung wird die
offensichtlich mit einem menschen und
wählen aus englisch angeblich bis zu 100
mal
man ist schon mehr digitalen raum
unterwegs als in der natur
man kommuniziert über digitale medien
schon mehr als von angesicht zu sein
über die quoten ich wünsche euch hier
auch die zukunft unseres landes und
unserer gesellschaft zeit dass wir das
miteinander sucht dass er die
kameradschaft untereinander trägt ich
wünsche euch dass ihr euren im
österreichischen bundesheeres wertvollen
und bereichern den beinen strecke in
eurem leben erkennt der mensch nicht
nicht vom brot allein lebt auch von der
beziehung zueinander und sogar wünsche
ich euch besiegen ihren grundwehrdienst
liebe kameradinnen und kameraden sprache
es ist etwas ganz wichtig ist es uns
gegeben wir werden weiter zur sprache
kommen
ihr werdet eine stimme haben und worauf
von dem meine stimme wo finde ich dass
ich gelobe sprechen und mit einem zu
dienen beschließen
das kommt damit er wusste maus und starb
es etwas das unmöglich unser innerstes
hervorzugehen des tages bringt es
kommunizieren
start ist es das was mit kultur zu tun
hat es gibt auch wenn die sprachkultur
wir haben auch die militärmusik halte da
auch die musik ist vielleicht an eine
strafe bis zum ausdruck bringen wie
nämlichen konkreten fall dass es sich
hier um einen feierlichen um einen
westlichen 8 hamburg bei gms gerüst zu
sagen und das was wir zu sagen haben wir
dann ein bereinigungen der akt sei es
ist ein öffentliches bekenntnis ist
nicht möglich vor ihm gelangen können
verhaftet dass ich mir bin dass ich
meinem land viele sondern es soll auch
zu sperren kommen einerseits die karten
in dem ich einmal hier bin meinen
leenstra see und ein paar anderen seite
auch im wort meine verwandten
geschwister
und feinde die hilfen seien sie werden
heute auf stolze zeugen seien auf eine
etwas andere art und weise zwar aber so
ergebnis bringt nämlich etwas zum
ausdruck wie ich vorhin gesagt habe er
aus der haft in diese nicht schon abends
übernehmen nicht nur das anlegen sondern
verantwortung aufzutragen in unserer
wobei bereitschaft dazu aber auch
konsequenzen dieser die brauchen
entscheidung konsequent aufzutragen
wer seinen namen er soll durch seine
sprache haben
er soll wirklich sichtbar sein und es
kommt dem lebens kommission richten
bevor die uniform uns zu leicht ist ein
ausflug diese zu tragen
sie ist dass die kennzeichen darf er
auch wofür ihr wofür wir stehen
das kommt noch diese angelogen selbst
auch zum ausdruck seid also auch wieder
stolz auf sie genug und vor allem lehnt
es auch im soldaten einnahmen aber ärger
mit seinem segen begleiten medien unsere
nation und für aline ist eben um den
herren braucht man die folgenden zum
gewinn des fahrer unseres ins bad zu
stellen
[Musik]
unter unserem himmel geheiligt werde
dein reich komme
dein wille geschehe im himmel so auf
erden
unser tägliches brot gib uns heute unter
die uns unsere schuld wie auch wir
vergeben unseren schuldigern und führe
uns nicht in versuchung sondern erlöse
uns trennt ist denn dein ist das reich
und die kraft und die herrliche wird
zuerst immer alles behindert niemals auf
nachts nicht gegen wolf führung seinem
leben erkennen und tun ich mir meiner
verantwortung wieder einen festen herzen
und einen freien geist zu sein macht
mich aufmerksamen kindern gegenüber
nicht zusammentun und gemeinsam lassen
bei dienstlichen haft in der
verantwortung meinem land gegenüber den
menschen die mir vertrauen wenn ich in
versuchung nicht widerstehen wenn ich
rede machte die mit den mutlosen zu
stehen und es neu zu versuchen leute
nicht durch das licht einer wahrheit
herr unser gott zu sehen diese jungen
menschen die heute feierlich die
republik österreich in münsters uns
erich zu schützen und sich für den
frieden mit allen kräften einzusetzen
nach einer verfahren dann in der ost
erfolgt die ansprache des
militärkommandanten von kärnten bringt
ihr weitergeht stammen
[Musik]
anlässlich der geschichte lernen was die
so laden soldatinnen vor allem aber
geschätzte anzugehören die rekruten
corona bild und die diversen
schutzmaßnahmen gelten auch natürlich
muss man die jungs oder ganz besonders
für uns soldaten und soldatinnen
angesammelt trotzdem entschieden ihren
diese angenommen in dieser form noch und
daraus der persönlichen anwesenheit
ihrer liebe angehören und durchzuführen
in dieser form gerade für sie haben
zugenommen
beim kunden die heutige tag ein ganz
besonderer tag ist und auch sein denn
ein drohendes ob sein vaterland spricht
man nicht so ohne weiteres aus heute und
morgen vergessen ein treuegelöbnis hat
auswirkungen auf die nächsten monate
solange sie ihren aktiv im ungefähren
dienst versehen aber darüber hinaus
zumindest ist zu ihrem 65
lebensjahr auswirkungen auf ihre
einstellung
ihr verhalten im fahrplan geschätzten
gerade den letzten monaten seit beginn
der krise haben einiges zu tage gebracht
die cola kirche hat nicht nur papiere
der auswirkung aufs persönlich ihr leben
zu hause familienleben mit
beschränkungen beschränkungen mit sich
gebracht wie es in dieser form noch nie
gegeben haben diese kirche massive
einschränkungen auswirkungen auf ihre
schulen oder arbeitsleben mitgebracht
wie sich einige von ihnen waren auch in
den letzten tagen wochen monaten die
kurzen im home office oder haben leider
schlimmstenfalls auch im beruf ihren job
verloren
diese kohler krise hat der bauern
gravierende auswirkungen und neue
herausforderungen an das österreichische
bundesheer mitgebracht geschätzte
soldaten soldatinnen grieche hat einiges
zu lange leben braucht sehr viel
positives für uns soldaten soldatinnen
sie hat gezeigt dass das österreichische
bundesheer eine unverzichtbare säule der
staaten in krisen- und
katastrophenmanagement es ist ganz viele
unserer geldpolitik wie sie sagt das ist
ungefähr ist dies verdient
die aufgaben auf längst in den letzten
monaten haben andere nicht mehr können
das österreichische bundesheer steht
bereit steht nicht nur der access der
windmarkt aufträge zu der fünf steht
bereit engagiert und motiviert
angebliche aufträge sache heranzugehen
dafür seien vorher der eintrager so
datenbank geschätzten rekrutinnen ich
erlaube mir schließlich noch mit einer
matte als sieger anzutreten
auch das österreichische bundesheer
durch höhen und tiefen die berühmte
pensionierungswelle ist es diese
herausforderung hier heute konkret
einschneiden dach geht auch an uns nicht
spurlos vorüber wieder viele us-soldaten
soldaten werden in den nächsten monaten
jahren in pension gingen in ihren
wohlverdienten ruhestand
daher mein appell an sie sollten sich
jeweils an diesen berufssoldaten ehrung
haben melden sich wir brauchen ziehen
wir brauchen sie um auch weiterhin der
österreichischen bevölkerung schutz und
hilfe in dieser qualität und quantität
in zukunft sicherstellen zu können und
der appell hinterhand
wie kann es soldaten hier anwesenden und
parteisoldaten sodann meiner welt an
ermöglichen sie denn jetzt aus zu vielen
regierungen eine dementsprechende
erlebnisreiche ausbildung zeitgemäße
ausbildung zeitgemäßer wert käselau
damit möglichst viele von ihnen gefallen
solange der uns selbst aktiver und
offizier office hier wo dann als
milizsoldaten in diesem sinne danke für
ihre bisher gezeigten leistungen
ich bin mir auch sicher dass viele viele
unter anderem gelungen der sekunden in
diversen einsätzen in der nächsten
monaten sehen werde alles gute danke für
ihre bisher gezeigten leistungen
nun erfolgt der eigentliche mühlenbruch
der angelogen mit dem nach strengen des
erlöses das zeugnis wird durch mario hat
ernährungs vorgeschoben
hierzu wird der einen seite soll das
funktionieren
vorträge
foto
das grüne gewissen islam zu sprechen
ich gelobe republik österreich zu
schützen und den gesetzen die russen zu
leisten die die tiere in der natur
geschätzten 50 und beschuldigen wirklich
um klar zu bedeuten wenn die christen
und alle kräfte müssten sich in
österreichischen volkes unterstreichen
[Musik]
hey
ja
[Musik]
entweder
diese speziellen therapie
und ernährung
oh oh
[Musik]
das ganze eigentlich übernehmen
vielen dank an alle inder kennen der
heute in ein besonderer dank gilt den
mit der notierung bankenverband den
generierten 1 fotos rainer haupt
akteuren us-regierungen regionen
wir wünschen ihnen neben schönes
vorgänger und einige gesund
[Musik]
liebe zu sehen die angelobung ist hier
mit vielen dank fürs zu sehen
ich wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende
und bleiben sie gesund